bon sortez tous vous
livre pourquoi tu n'as pas ton livre
parce que je l'ai pas et pourquoi donc
madame je vais te dire que je l'ai pas
bon on va faire l'exercice au tableau
non je peux pas tu me manques de respect
là et
alors ne tolère pas cette attitude
zedine accompagne l' CPE toute façon je
m'en fous je voulais pas rester une
minute et tu auras 2 heur d'é colle je
m'en
fous pourquoi tu me regardes tu es pas
en colère tu te regarde pas ce n'est pas
après moi que tu es en colère ben non
mais qu'est-ce qui s'est passé c'est la
prof nous a de TI nos affaires et moi
j'ff pas mes affaires après la prof m'a
dit d'aller réaliser ce tableau je
voulais pas plus tous les autres sont
ont rigolé de moi et ça m'a mis en
colère donc si je comprends bien tu as
peur que les autres se ment de toi et
quand tu me vois dans la coup tu
continues d'être en colère oui c'est
ça donc tu aurais pu faire quoi alors
ben je ne sais pas moi peut-être
d'essayer de faire l'exercice même si je
comprenais rien et de toute façon la
prof est là pour m'aider et les gens ne
se
ne rigole pas se moque pas dé
courageux mais ce que tu dois faire
c'estaller t'excuser auprès de la
prof
bonsoir
bonjour excusez-moi madame je suis venu
m'excuser de mon comportement et de
d'avoir manqué de respect et je vais
bien essayer de faire l'exercice vous me
le permettez j'cep c'est bon j'accepte
tes excuses tu peux faire l'exercice
ouais
madame est-ce que c'est
bon
euh oui c'est bien retourne à ta
place
je t trouvé courageux d'être revenu en
classe et t'excuser et de faire
l'exercice merci pourant c'était pas
dur on se
retrouve c'est ça que j'aime à l'école
que les gens s'entendent c'est pas on a
le droit d'être en colère mais plus
important c'est d'en
parler cela évite d'être agressif et
violent en reconnaissant ces émotions on
arrive m à les gérer et à trouver des
solutions pour mieux vivre
ensemble c'est bien d'aider les autres à
se sentir mieux et éviter tous les
problèmes comme les menaces les insultes
la violence et autre
chose la violence ne résout pas le
problème ce qui résout le problème c'est
d'en
parler la colère est comme l'orage on
peut faire revenir le sourire comme le
BE
temps c'est moi Michela qui fait la pro
c'est moi Man qui fait l'exclu c'est moi
Naira qui fait la
médiatrice sal n est là pour arrête la
violence je m'appelle fressignac je suis
le principal le boss ici c'est moi avec
tous mes amis de Mayan à salami derrière
la Déclaration des droits de l'homme et
maintenant je suis là pour leur donner
de l'espérance pour un monde sans
violence les réalisatrice on est là pour
vous dire vivons ensemble sans
violence malgré je grandi de la violence
je réussi à m'en sortir la violence ne
nous mène nul part des moyens pour nous
en sortir se connaîre séparer rigoler se
rencontrer pour
s'amuser ensemble de la musique pass un
m du respect pour je passe mon chemin
mal crol
oreill ple l'ambiance dans ok tous les
jeunes se mett à chanter danser rigoler
c'est ça le chemin du bonheur du respect
se connaître se parer rigoler se
rencontrer pour s'amuser bouger ensemble
faire de la musique un message du
respect